let's start with the afc game a rematch
both games are rematches a regular
season contest it was 35 32 in nashville
this time it gets played out in kansas
city just two years ago the titans went
to kansas city and won a wild card game
there plenty of guys still on both teams
from two years ago who went through that
experience but for the most part the
team's dramatically different especially
at an important position like starting
quarterback
starting quarterback patrick mahomes of
the kansas city chiefs has been
talking this week specifically at his
wednesday press conference about last
year about playing through adversity
about things that are going to be
relevant on sunday so we'll let you hear
some of what he said and react to it
let's begin with that very important
question of what he did learn from the
experience a year ago when the patriots
beat the chiefs on their own field in
overtime here's my homes from wednesday
last year they caught us a little off
guard with the coverages that they
played at the beginning of the game and
we made adjustments and were able to
score points uh later in the game but
you want to make sure that you're that
you're just preparing for everything you
know that this is a good defense i do do
a lot of different things play a lot of
man to play a lot of zone and so you
know that they're going to throw the
different coverages out there against
you and so just trying to prepare
yourself for whatever whatever their
game plan is and trying to adjust as
quickly as possible
and chris you know he's referring to the
thing you spotted in the film from last
year the man coverage underneath the
safety who apparently was covering the
deep middle of the field who was shading
over to tyree kills area and shut him
down in that game and the titans very
adept at rolling out different coverages
zone and man kevin byer their safety
told me after the 34-13 win over the
browns way back in week one we threw
every coverage in the book at baker
mayfield and it worked can it work
against mahomes now that he's two years
in as a starter he's seen plenty of
things
can you confuse him with all these
different coverages that the titans may
be using well yeah that's the thing
right can you confuse him you can
confuse him but the greatness of the
kansas city chiefs and i know you know
we've discussed this a little bit is how
many times you watch you know i'll sit
there watch film or you and me will be
watching the game on sunday and we see a
replay and we go whoa it's great defense
everybody's covered but then mahomes
buys time or fades away in the pocket
and then kelsey or hill somebody
uncovers and that's where they're
magical i mean even this play we're
showing on replay right now the first
titans match up nobody's open but then
patrick mahomes runs up in the pocket
and jumps and throws a pass and uncovers
the guy who's covered you know so that's
what's frustrating about the kansas city
chiefs and he never panics that's just
the way he is there was a number of
plays last week with the texans they
tried to double travis kelsey he just
sticks with it and goes ah at some point
he'll shake free of this double coverage
and i'll fit it in there and zoom he
fits it in there so it's he's he's not
flustered when he is fooled i guess is
what my thing is mike and tennessee they
do have some of those new england
principles i would think that they're
going to try to double kelsey in certain
situations or a tyree kill but with
kansas city and their talent and their
creativity on the offensive side of the
ball it's easier said than done
and the other thing that they have in
their favor came from the game on sunday
that saw them rally back from a 24 point
deficit you pick up confidence you pick
up a sense that you're not going to give
up that if you fall behind it's all
going to work out that's something else
patrick mahomes addressed yesterday when
he was asked about handling the ups and
downs the highs and lows the twists and
turns of big games here he is on that
topic
the biggest thing is just dealing with
adversity uh when you when you're
playing in these type of football games
not everything's going to be going to be
great you're not going to get everything
the exact way you want it but you have
to find a way to find a way to win find
a way to fight and i felt like this last
game definitely prepared us with being
down 24-0 just finding a way to come out
on top in the end
and i think that there really is value
in that isn't there when you know
that you can come back from that kind of
a deficit doesn't that give you a nice
kick in the butt heading into your
second straight opportunity to get to a
super bowl without question you know and
again i'm not patrick mahomes nor do i
have the experiences he had but like in
my you know year of starting back in
2005 like we won a few games like late
in the game you know come back wins
fourth quarter comebacks and it makes
you feel indestructible as a team to
where you just go oh it doesn't matter
no matter what the circumstance is you
know we're cool and calm under pressure
and we believe we can execute and get it
done now they're going to have that you
know times five when you're down 24-0
and that and that type of spotlight of a
football game so yeah to your point 100
it's going to make them and their
offense feel
there's never going to be panic on
sunday and we see in playoffs right
teams panic because you start to go oh
my gosh i'm down 14 nothing we got to
make a play here or we're going to be
home next week we got to do something
the coach goes oh gosh we got to make
some so everybody gets out of their
comfort zone and it snowballs andy reed
did a great job last week of not letting
anybody get crazy or panic and so did
patrick mahomes on the sideline and yeah
i don't think no matter what happens how
that game starts on sunday that the
chiefs will be phased and a lot of that
is because of what happened last week
the way you started that comment it gave
me a vision of a day
45 50 years from now
when
your grandkids are clustered around you
and they say papa tell us what it was
like to play professional football and
you say to them well kids in all my year
of starting all my year
all my year
here look here here's the thing the
chiefs are going to gain their yards the
chiefs are going to score their points
yes right
but i i still can't get away from
the fact that the titans offense is
basically that middle school team with
the one kid who's gone through puberty
who is shaving who is bigger than
everyone else and they just give him the
football on every play and he he gains
25 yards or more on every play if you
can't stop derek henry does it matter
what the chiefs do offensively well it
does because if they can't stop him then
they you know hey mike this might go
back into one of those conversations
that we had early in the year if they
feel like tennessee's bleeding the clock
away and oh man every drive is eight
minutes long and they're running the
ball then they gotta do the you know the
old you know do it or get off the pot
method like you know
get it done crap or get off the pot
sorry for that lack of a better phrase
out there but that's all i can come up
with all right come up with another one
you sure there's not there's another way
to put it you sure you don't want to put
it down i can i can i just don't want to
get you in trouble but i do think that
kansas city's got to be wary of that in
case that the tennessee titans do
control the line of scrimmage they might
need to just start going to what we
talked about earlier this year all right
let's blitz let's be aggressive either
we start making some tackles for a loss
or he breaks a long run and scores but
so be it our money our assets our talent
of our football teams on offense at
least they're back on the football field
so that'll be the interesting thing mike
but now the first time around it wasn't
like that the first time they played the
kansas city chiefs dominated the game
really for the most part they controlled
the ball for 38 minutes they had 530
yards a total offense they had 28 first
downs that was patrick mahomes first
game back i watched back that game
yesterday certainly interesting the run
game by the tennessee titans dangerous
we know that but man did the did the
kansas city chiefs have chances to
really you know i'm not going to say
blow out the tennessee titans but had
chances to really kind of put them in a
real tough spot early on and messed it
up with penalties damien williams
fumbled and they picked up a you know a
50-yard touchdown mahomes missed a few
throws we showed it at that time so i
just think this is a different type
chiefs team all together i know it's a
different titans team too but this was a
demarcation of the changing of the
chiefs defense this game and like i said
that was mahomes first game back and i
think he missed a few plays in that one
that he wouldn't miss this week
yeah 35-32 the final score of that when
a blocked field goal iced it for the
tennessee titans and let's say that the
chiefs do come up with a way
to
keep derek henry from gashing them the
way he's gashed so many teams recently
do we think ryan tannehill can do what a
guy like kirk cousins can't when you
take away his running game can tanah
hill
win the game with his arm if derek henry
can't win the game with his legs i think
he's a little more
um scary than kirk cousins that way to
where he can make plays off schedule i
mean we know what kind of athlete he is
he's got a bigger arm than kirk cousins
too quite honestly so i do and i think
you know we know aj brown and corey
davis and jonu smith yeah they're real
good too i'll tell you the other element
of this and this popped in the first
game and this got them started when they
were down 10 nothing and we saw it last
week khalif raymond yeah number 14 for
the tennessee titans he changes their
offense a little bit he gives them
another weapon he really does his speed
it's again it's a little like that
houston formula when you start to go
whoa it's raymond it's corey davis as aj
brown that's a pretty good three along
with that run game that could be scary
so i do have faith but kansas city's
defense is not the defense of last year
they're gonna be tougher in the
secondary than we're used to uh so yeah
tennessee wants to run the ball but i
think if it gets desperate that they can
rely on ryan tannehill
yeah and that kansas city defense
remember last year the the narrative for
the chiefs coming out of the season was
keep doing what you're doing on offense
if your defense is just a little bit
better you're going to the super bowl
right and it is more than a little bit
better that's the thing
coming up later today we'll be doing the
mega pix podcast and i'm going to have
to make a selection as will you in both
of these games and chris i've been going
back and forth i was texting my son last
night he eventually told me every
possible permutation of of super bowl
representatives it's like well you're
guaranteed to be right on one of them
and and it's impossible to not keep
changing your mind because i could see
either team win this game just like i
could see either team win the nfc game
yeah i mean agreed there's no doubt
about it i mean the tennessee titans
yeah we all sit here and go oh well you
know you got to stop the run well
everybody's been saying that for like
the last six weeks and they run for 150
and 180 yards like stopping the run now
with the tennessee titans is like this
this is where the line has moved to you
know can we keep derek henry under 130
you know when it gets above 130 that's
when you know you're being dominated the
line of scrimmage and you have a chance
to lose but like under 130 is like a win
for a defense right now it really is you
got to look at it and go no we just
don't want them to get 180 you know 210
you know something like that and they're
capable of doing that and that's when
they're scary and that's when they're
kind of unbeatable
i like your thought though and usually
we think of it more in the passing game
yeah sell out blitz and if they're going
to get you over the top and score a
touchdown fine we put our offense back
on the field exactly right so so what do
you i mean for me
what do you do
to sell out to stop the run do you put
11 guys at the line of scrimmage yeah
you could certainly call those bluffs
you know there's certain types of
blitzes too that are a little more you
know uh you know they're better for the
run game as compared to maybe a
quarterback blitz where you know you
just slant the line one way and maybe
have one or two guys come off the weak
side edge so now then you have all the
gaps accounted for but yeah you got five
or six guys shooting up field after the
ball carrier so yes it would be
something like that certainly uh but
yeah i think they they need to have that
fail-safe plan there you know again too
let's not forget the tennessee titans
they're past defense like it's nothing
special so kansas city should not be
afraid to get in the shootout it's the
24th pass defense in football they
haven't been able to cover people all
year long so if it gets into like oh wow
it's ten nothing and tennessee's rally
grounding and pounding and running the
clock start blitzing start creating
chaos get your money makers back on the
field and that's mahomes watkins hill
and kelsey
and i think the chiefs have the guys to
do it now it would be helpful to have
chris jones who continues to be
day-to-day with a calf injury but uh but
with with frank clark with tyron matthew
i it helps it does gives them a presence
they didn't have last year when they
were trying to slow down the new england
patriots and ultimately failed to do so
in overtime
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports